[Music]
[Applause]
i have failed a lot in my life trying to
pursue the perfect shot or idea
[Applause]
get out of here
[Music]
in this video i can't down my 10 most
disastrous moments caught on camera
[Music]
hey i'm dan mays i've carried this book
around with me for the past 10 years
it's filled with the most challenging
ideas i've ever had and this show is
dedicated to getting them done
welcome to the brew show
[Music]
so
[Music]
i [ __ ] up many times before and for
the most part i've never shared these
fails with you
being a filmmaker i'm always trying to
one-up myself on each idea and this has
led me to doing some pretty risky [ __ ]
in this video i'm gonna count down the
10 worst fails in my life from bad to
really bad
[Applause]
in 2012 10 years ago i traveled through
the narmad desert in angola in pursuit
of the perfect wave that had never been
ridden before the car was driving broke
down and i got stuck in the desert with
no food or water for more than 30 hours
till a local by chance drove past and
put us in their car we then had to
abandon our car it was super scary and
throughout angola when you're driving
around you just see the skeleton remains
of cars because once a car breaks down
or gets stuck in the desert there's no
saving it
this next fail made a great film and is
still one of my favorites however it got
deleted resulting in me losing around 50
000 us dollars i flew with two friends
into the brazilian amazon to document a
magic mushroom chip and the positive
effects it has on depression and anxiety
i spent a month in total making this
film and when i published it was
received really well and it got a lot of
views really quickly until youtube
decided to delete it based on it being
illegal even though when we were in
brazil it was legal to take psilocybin
very bad news um last night dan was in a
pretty bad accident in the middle of
2018 i'd been living in new york for a
few months working with casey neistat
and it was super chaotic and i was
usually just rushing all over the place
and on one day i had my camera in my
hand i was flying down the road on my
electric skateboard it was raining
a car pulled out in front of me in the
bike lane and bang crashed into the side
of it and broke my shoulder in two
places this resulted in me paying a
large medical bill in america and then i
still had to fly back to south africa
and get operated on and yeah i missed a
lot of work because of this
in 2020 i was directing a film where we
needed a tiny replica an exact replica
of a ford truck we spent about a month
getting a perfect miniature replica
designed and 3d printed when we started
shooting we realized that everything
worked perfectly except the wheels
which was absolutely ridiculous because
we had to drive on this rotational set
so we had to change the entire concept
then and there
no matter how hard i planned
something goes wrong why did it come
down to the last day the last minute i
had to go to a kids store close by and i
bought a tiny vw car and then we had a
search for someone who drove that exact
car this was a complete nightmare it was
really really stressful but in the end
the film sort of turned out okay
[Applause]
in july 2019 i flew to mumbai to make a
film even after i was warned about
monsoon season i thought to myself how
bad could it really be when the car
picked us up we were already waiting in
around a half a foot of water and it
just continued getting worse and worse
at one point the driver just stopped the
car lifted his legs and started praying
this was no joke it was really really
hectic at one point he opened the window
for some reason and water just started
gushing through
my drone and b-roll camera got
completely soaked and they both broke as
well as my film was also delayed by
seven days because of all of this
[Applause]
in 2015 i was in mozambique making a
film about the rats that can sniff out
landmines which in itself is a whole
other story when we got to the minefield
there were a bunch of mortars which are
explosives that are strong enough to
blow up a large vehicle from under the
ground
my dad saw a stacked pile and just
assumed it was a bunch of already
detonated ones so he walked over to the
pile and picked one up and a security
guard saw him and started screaming and
running towards him so my dad just
suddenly dropped it i remember seeing
this whole process in slow motion it
bounced and landed on the opposite side
of the firing mechanism if it had landed
on the firing mechanism everyone in
about a two meter radius would have just
blown into pieces this was a really big
eye opener for all of us the whole crew
and
yeah we are really lucky to be alive
when i was 19 i dropped out of college
and with absolutely no knowledge of
business i decided to start a business a
film production business i seeked out
and i got granted a really large
investment but i continually
valued art over commerce and this landed
me completely broke and with a company
then and minus i lost a lot of
friendships because of this a lot of
trust with people and i had to work
really really hard for the next few
years to just be known as somebody
reliable again and somebody worthy of
getting hired
okay to this day this was still the
stupidest idea i've ever had for a video
i decided to not try find a needle in a
haystack but rather a piece of hay in a
needle stack so i bought a bunch of
needles and i hit a piece of hay in the
middle i got my friend gabe and put a 10
000 us dollar reward on it ever found at
first it was a complete disaster waiting
to happen we got spiked by many needles
but luckily came out with no major
injuries or infections i wasted around
fifteen thousand us dollars trying to
make this film
and it was only live for about five
minutes on youtube till i realized how
stupid it was and deleted it
this is the second worst fail of my life
so far i'd been developing my career
alongside casey neistat in new york city
for about a year when i got myself
deported from america by not having the
correct documentation on hand at the
time of being questioned in an airport
in ireland i was then stuck between
borders i missed my flight my apartment
stood dormant for a few months and it
caused a huge loss of opportunities for
me it took about two years thousands of
dollars and a lot of work to try and get
my visa back
however i am now all good to go
in 2008 just as i had finished school i
flew to bali with a few friends to surf
and write stories for future videos
about 30 days into the trip i got into a
car accident which resulted in me
getting drugs planted on me marijuana to
be specific which is hugely illegal and
punished with the death sentence i've
created an entire video about this
experience which i'll link here as well
as in the description of the video but
long story short i was able to escape
prison and get flown out by the south
african embassy this was by miles the
most dangerous situation i've ever been
caught in in history
when [ __ ] goes horribly wrong it's
really difficult for me to zoom out and
see that maybe everything does happen
for a reason i have no idea what that
reason is all i do know is that i'm
still here every day making films
so i'm just gonna try and learn from the
stuff that i could have done differently
and surrender to everything else that i
can't control
and keep on keeping on doing what i love
which is this
making films other than that don't
forget you're awesome and i'll see you
soon
one
you